ja meine damen und herren wir haben in
den letzten tagen sehr intensiv uns
beschäftigt mit unserer heutigen
zusammenkunft und wir haben heute
miteinander beraten
per video-konferenz wo steht unser land
im blick auf die epidemie die von dem
corona virus ausgeht
und ich möchte mich bei den
bundesländern bedanken dass wir die
gemeinsame linie die wir beschlossen
haben auch durchgesetzt haben und dass
wir uns heute verabredet haben auch die
nächste phase gemeinsam dann zu
gestalten was hat uns heute geleitet als
erstes möchte ich allen menschen in
deutschland noch einmal ganz herzlich
danken den bürgerinnen und bürgern die
ihr leben verändert haben die verzichtet
haben auf kontakte die sich einschränken
nicht weil sie der regierung etwa einen
gefallen tun sondern weil sie ihren
mitmenschen helfen wollen und das ist
etwas ganz ganz starkes und wichtiges
was unser land bei aller einschränkungen
im augenblick erlebt und es zeigt dass
wenn etwas wirklich gutes entstehen soll
in unserem land in deutschland dann ist
das mit den bürgern und durch die bürger
geschehen und dafür bin ich dankbar
wir haben etwas erreicht das haben uns
heute auch das robert koch institut
bestätigt und wir haben etwas erreicht
was ja keineswegs von anfang an sicher
war nämlich dass unsere ärzte unsere
pflegekräfte alle die im medizinischen
bereich in den krankenhäusern arbeiten
nicht überfordert wurden sie leisten
enormes und viele sind auch unter
größter anspannung tätig aber es ist so
gewesen dass unser gesundheitssystem am
laufen gehalten werden konnte und ich
möchte mich ganz herzlich bei allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern in dem
gesundheitlichen bereich inklusive der
niedergelassenen ärzte und der vielen
menschen die in diesem bereich arbeiten
genauso in den seniorenheimen und
ähnlichen einrichtungen ganz herzlich
bedanken
und ich denke natürlich in dieser stunde
auch an die infizierten die die korona
krankheit erleben oder schon
haben wir wissen ja auch dass wir leider
auch schon eine vielzahl von opfern zu
beklagen hatten
was wir erreicht haben das ist ein
zwischenerfolg
nicht mehr und nicht weniger und ich
betone es ist ein zerbrechlicher
zwischenerfolg das hat herr wieder vom
robert-koch-institut uns heute noch
einmal gesagt wir haben die faktoren die
dafür einen aussage treffen in eine gute
richtung entwickelt aber wir haben auch
nicht viel spielraum sondern wir müssen
jetzt ganz konzentriert weitermachen
deshalb hat unsere beratungen bestimmt
dass es jetzt kein falsches vorpreschen
geben darf auch wenn die besten
absichten dahinter stehen sondern wir
müssen verstehen dass wir so lange mit
dem virus leben müssen wie es keine
medikamente und insbesondere keinen
impfstoff gibt und wir müssen die
erfolge sichern die wir erreicht haben
und deshalb ist es sozusagen wenn wir
darüber sprechen welche schritte in
richtung einer eines etwas mehr zulassen
von öffentlichen leben die wir ja alle
gehen wollen wir gehen dann müssen wir
sagen es ist geht um äußerste vorsicht
die wir weiten lassen müssen und das hat
unsere beratungen heute auch geprägt
denn es geht jedes mal um menschen
wir haben uns geeinigt dass wir
natürlich ausgehend von unseren
beschlüssen die wir am 12
16 und 22 märz 2020 gefasst haben und
dass es auch weiter entscheidend bleibt
dass bürgerinnen und bürger in der
öffentlichkeit ein mindestabstand von
1,5 metern einhalten und sich dort nur
alleine mit einer weiteren nicht im
haushalt lebenden personen oder im an
kreis der angehörigen des eigenen
hausstandes aufhalten
das bild weiterhin und die verstöße
dagegen werden auch weiter von den
ordnungsbehörden geahndet um zukünftig
infektionsketten schnell zu erkennen ist
mir etwas ganz wichtig und ich bedanke
mich bei den ländern die auch zum großen
teil ihre gesundheitsbehörden schon
aufgestockt haben wenn wir jetzt mehr
öffentliche
leben zu lassen in kleinen schritten
dann ist es ganz wichtig dass wir noch
besser die infektionsketten verfolgen
können es muss unser ziel sein jede
infektionskette verfolgen zu können
dafür werden wir arbeiten wir auch an
einer app aber vor allen dingen ist es
die aufgabe der gesundheitsbehörden
denn wenn wir das können dann können wir
auch infektionsherde eingrenzen und dann
ist die lockere lockerung im bereich des
öffentlichen lebens nicht mehr so
gravierend weil wir ja wissen wo
entstehen infektionsherde wenn wir das
nicht haben dann werden wir nicht so
erfolgreich sein und deshalb ist das von
ganz ganz entscheidender bedeutung
wir wollen natürlich eine gute
versorgung mit tess kapazitäten wir
wollen an der medizinischen
schutzausrüstung arbeiten hier haben wir
sehr ausführlich über die frage der
sogenannten alltags masken gesprochen
und sprechen uns dafür aus dass es
empfehlenswert ist dass es geboten ist
sozusagen diese alltags masken auch zu
verwenden im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und in beim einkaufen
ich glaube das ist ein wichtiger punkt
der jetzt auch weiterentwickelt wurde in
unseren beschlüssen wir werden also den
bürgerinnen und bürgern die nutzung
entsprechender alltags masten
insbesondere im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und beim einkauf
dringend empfehlen wir glauben dass wir
in mit jedem tag jetzt mehr diese
alltags masken bekommen werden und dass
das dann auch dazu dienen sollte andere
menschen zu schützen und wenn es viele
tun dann eben auch sich selbst zu
schützen
wir haben immer pflegeheime gesprochen
hier wird es ganz wichtig sein dass wir
uns altenheime dass wir individuelle
konzepte entwickeln um nicht die soziale
isolation der menschen in diesen heimen
zu haben und trotzdem die
sicherheitsstandards einzuhalten
und wir haben natürlich eine
ausführliche diskussion über
kindergärten schulen und hochschulen
geführt und ich weiß wie viele menschen
in deutschland gerade diese diskussion
verfolgen denn das ist natürlich eine
ganz ganz schwierige situation für
eltern dass ihre kinder nicht
andere freunde treffen können dass es
nur eine notbetreuung gibt dass die
allermeisten zu hause sind und trotzdem
müssen wir um die anforderungen auch an
den infektionsschutz einzuhalten um
menschenleben zu sichern wir ganz
behutsam ganz schrittweise vorgehen
das ist uns heute auch gelungen indem
wir uns vor allen dingen erst einmal auf
die abschlussklassen die prüfung machen
müssen konzentrieren in einem nächsten
schritt auf die dann prüfung machen oder
schulwechsel vor sich haben und dass die
kultusministerkonferenz uns dann nochmal
ein ausführliches konzept vorlegt
genauso wie die jugend ministerkonferenz
denn wir können nur schrittweise dann
nach dem 4
langsam wieder die einzelnen schulen
dinge machen es muss in reduzierten
gruppen seien es muss ein schulbus
konzept da sein es muss ein pausen
konzept da sein das wird also eine hohe
logistische aufwand zu betreiben seien
und deshalb bei bedarf das einer
intensiven vorbereitung und ich weiß wie
viel hat sich das noch für eltern
bedeutet aber ich glaube es ist einfach
notwendig wenn wir sagen wir müssen in
der pandemie mit diesem virus leben und
das bereitet sich dort auch an der
betriebe müssen auch hygiene konzepte
anfertigen und werden dann am vierten
mai ihre arbeit wieder aufnehmen können
wenn die schutzmaßnahmen ausreichend
sind wir haben intensiv über das hohe
gut der religionsfreiheit gesprochen und
auch über die veranstaltung die
natürlich bei den von den kirchen
stattfinden ich möchte den kirchen ein
ganz herzliches dankeschön sagen denn
sie haben gerade jetzt über ostern viel
phantasie bewiesen dass obwohl keine
gottesdienste stattfinden konnten
menschen auch ihren glauben leben
konnten wir wollen dass religiöse
feierlichkeiten veranstaltungen und
zusammenkünfte anderer
glaubensgemeinschaften zunächst weiter
nicht stattfinden aber es wird noch in
dieser woche ein gespräch von
ministerpräsidenten und dem
bundesministerium des innern geben über
die frage wie man einen einvernehmlichen
weg für das weitere vorgehen findet
wichtig ist dass wir das wirtschaftliche
die wirtschaftliche tätigkeit im großen
ganzen ja nicht
kunden haben sondern nur dort wo es
publikumsverkehr gibt hier haben wir uns
natürlich sehr ausführlich mit der frage
der eröffnung weiterer geschäfte fast
hier haben wir auf der einen seite
gesagt es können geschäfte bis zu 800
quadratmetern auf machen allerdings mit
guten konzepten für die nutzung dieser
constant dieser geschäfte mit hygiene
konzepten und wir müssen auch schauen
dass nicht sozusagen auf den straßen
sich riesige schlangen bilden auch das
gehört mit zum verantwortungsbereich und
das wollen wir werden auch eine vielzahl
von vorarbeit vorbereitungsarbeiten
geführt werden müssen
wir werden viel in die forschung
investieren das ist unstrittig um gerade
auch unseren teil dazu zu leisten
noch mehr zu erforschen was wie viele
menschen hatten diese infektion schon
was wie können wir beitragen zu einem
impfstoff entwicklung welche medikamente
sind wichtig und es ich darf sagen dass
wir auch gerade seitens des bundes hier
ein sehr großzügiger finanzieller
unterstützung alles tun damit der
forschungsstandort deutschland auch
seinen beitrag zur bewältigung dieser
pandemie leisten kann abschließend wir
werden uns immerhin 14 tages abständen
mit dem weiteren entwicklungen befassen
wir wollen sehen welche auswirkungen
haben die lockerungs möglichkeit lieber
heute ins auge gefasst haben auf die
entwicklung der infektion und in diesem
sinne ist es uns deshalb werden wir uns
deshalb am 30 april wieder darüber
unterhalten was passiert dann nach dem
dritten mai die spanne die wir jetzt ins
auge gefasst haben ist sie zwischen dem
zwanzigsten april und den dritten und
dann werden wir in weiteren schritten
vorgehen und es wird jetzt ganz davon
abhängen wie entwickeln sich die
infektionsraten ich sagte schon wir
haben da nicht viele spielräume und
deshalb hoffe ich dass alle weiter so
mitmachen und die regeln einhalten das
alles ermöglicht uns dann ein kleines
stück immer weiter öffentliches leben
wie wir es gewohnt sind aber eben in der
pandemie
das heißt anders und mit anderen regeln